dans le 12 45 de m6 on a découvert une
demande en mariage très original d'une
d'un jeune anglais à sa petite amie
demandé sa copine en mariage sans
qu'elle s'en rende compte c'est le petit
jeu auquel s'est adonné un britannique
pendant tout un mois après 23 fausses
demandes et 10 a finalement trouvé le
moment idéal et à la dignité
donc 23 fausse demande en mariage à
emilie lopez à cacher donc cesser de
manger en mariage à cette fois il fait
un se débrouille pour faire le sale
fille visiblement et vit dans une grotte
elle n'a pas accès à son insu internet
parce qu'elle n'a pas vu les demandes
avant de passer donc à l'acte et de
faire la réelle demande en mariage et il
lui a offert donc la bague avec l'album
photos des 23 autres demandes qu'elle
n'a pas vu qu'est ce qu'on en pense
gilles verdez gilles les demandes en
mariage ça me connaît je n'ai aucun
humour là dessus petit détail il a fait
de cette pauvre dame la risée
internationale d'internet
elle est maintenant ridicule pourquoi
j'ai dit tu es je trouve ça extrêmement
agressif sous les dehors bonhommes comme
ça et patelin ce monsieur a brisé cette
jeune femme elle est ridicule aux yeux
du monde alors il a il a cassé le mythe
du mariage mais il a il a brisé ce qui
est une demande en mariage
ce monsieur est un briseur de rêve c'est
de rire est quand elle a vu les le
voulez vous qu'elle fasse a donc pouvoir
se cacher d'accord mais moi je veux bien
être brisés comme elle je suis désolé 24
demande en mariage
enfin 25 ans tout ça fait toujours 25 à
voir donc puisque moi mais moi aussi ça
se trouve il ya quelqu'un qui vous
demande en mariage depuis des années qui
se meut qui met les photos sur les
réseaux de vous l'avez pas vu c'est
parce qu'ils assument pas non mais
peut-être mais c'est mal c'est ou comme
gilles vous dit finalement une casse le
côté très solennelle de la demande en
mariage
et après tout est en fait il en fait un
jeu alors que c'est qu'elle c'est un
moment particulier où est ce que vous
dites maintenant ça fait partie de la
demande ces 23 autres demandes mais moi
je vous explique je vous arrête tout de
suite même si j'ai une demande de
mariage dans les égouts de paris
je suis heureuse c'est à dire à partir
du moment où c'est une demande en
mariage il ya plein d'amour en libye il
dit n'importe quoi parce qu'en fait il a
le traumatisme de la demande en mariage
mais elle est magnifique cette demande
en mariage
les photos sont très rigolote et c'est
trop trop mignon elle essayait d un beau
souvenir va essayer de mettre en scène
son amour
franchement d'accord de paix vous il
faut au contraire s'amuser autant
d'efforts c'est vous vous quoi qu'on
fasse
vous trouve rien c'est attendrissant oui
enfin moi j'aimerais surtout qu'on me
demande devrait encore très bien que
vous avez compris est encore lancé
l'appel ça fait quand même un encas
lance un appel faudrait y est dès
maintenant
non mais j'y lis les rats boulet du
coeur elle aussi romantique que thibault
ce n'est pas un compliment
je suis désolé je trouve ça hyper beau à
bafoussam et oui une demande en mariage
c'est censé être quelque chose dont on
se souvient toute sa vie là la nana le
mec l'aiment tellement qu'il a demandé
24 fois en mariage les restos dans ces
24 soit plus que tout se tient au vol
sur cinq est fou il aime 24 fois plus
que tous les mecs qu'offrir de gilles un
petit peu quand même malgré tout moi
j'imagine aussi que peut-être alors elle
peut aussi alors là la paille ça n'a pas
été le cas mais elle aurait pu être déçu
en imaginant que ben à chaque fois il
l'a fait pour se donner du coeur à
l'ouvragé qu'il est il n'a pas faire
réellement une bonne fois pour toutes
avec le choeur tremblant avec le genou à
terre avec l'âme vous avez côtoyé
thibault vous devenez cynique mais ça ne
l'est pas du tout valérie benaïm non
s'ils ne l'aiment pas ils s'aiment lui
mais n'a même pas elle la voilà gilles
se rapproche un petit peu de la vérité
vous êtes tous brillants et si vous
n'avez pas compris on voit qu'une vaste
blague tout ça dimanche l'important dans
cette histoire c'est de ne pas se faire
choper voudrait dire que je vais
d'ailleurs essayé comme ma chérie n'est
pas connecté frêche lucide le fer et le
but c'est l'adrénaline qui a à se dire
si elle se retourne je vais être obligé
la demande en mariage a battu par avec
romantique ça le truc qui aidera voulait
bien concept
la dernière demande s'est fait choper en
fait il est pas vraiment diriger de
retourner la situation mais à la base
c'est pour faire marrer les potes je le
comprends et donc qu'il vient de mettre
ça sur les réseaux sociaux il s'amuse tu
mérites qu'elles disent non c'est pas
prévu c'est pas prévu à bali dont elle
s'est perdue sert qu elle nous regarde
pas